how much do you know about the
speedforce
mr. source of my power so it makes me a
speedster yes and no get your hands off
that hard body I'm sorry that sounded
way better in my head
[Music]
I lost my speed what do you mean you
lost your speed everybody it's Charlie
so we need to talk about stealing and
transferring the Speed Force we just had
a big scene during legends of tomorrow
this week I'll address a little bit of
the episode because Mullis showed how
powerful he was but because the flash is
on break this is a good opportunity to
talk about the flash transferring and
giving speed for some things that you
see Godspeed do a lot especially during
that first volume of the flash rebirth
so if you're not a big comic book reader
I'll explain the difference between the
way God speed takes people's speed in
the way that they've done it on the TV
show so far there's been a couple
different ways that they've shown it but
if you are finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos and there is a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter that is just be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video but the
big thing with that Speed Force wormhole
alien explainer what do you know about
the Speed Force is the Speed Force of
the TV show I mean this is like a little
bit different than the comic book Speed
Force in that there are Speed Force
wormhole aliens so it's meant to let you
know that there's a sentence to it there
is an intelligence but it's more like a
garden that has gardeners you can steal
from the garden even though the
gardeners can bestow speed upon people
so like they can take Barry's speed if
they want to they use agents but they
are rogue speedsters or evil speedsters
like the reverse-flash or anybody from
the reverse-flash family they can steal
from it without the consent of the Speed
Force wormhole aliens there's a big
event coming up in the comics where
Barry is going to be fighting Wally West
it's called flash war and it's gonna be
this war of ideologies along with a
physical war like they'll physically
fight each other but it's also about the
different ways that they perceive the
Speed Force they might get into a little
more of the spirituality the Zenoss of
Wally West's in the way he's connected
to the Speed Force versus the way that
Barry is connected to the Speed Force
but that gets a little more complicated
and it's not absolutely necessary for
the way we're talking about stealing
speed right now so we'll talk a little
bit more about the mythology of the
Speed Force when we get to flash war
later this year but on the TV show what
Mallis is doing is literally taking the
speed from him charging it into an
electrical boat the way that Barry
throws lightning and hitting him with it
couple of reasons why that's a big deal
one because Wally has no eye
how he did it and it's a combination of
a couple different abilities that we saw
on the flash during season two in season
one so if you remember blackout from the
flash season one he absorbed electricity
the Speed Force is kind of like Dark
Matter electricity so he was able to
take that from Barry
[Applause]
[Music]
that's kind of what it looked like when
Mallis was taking Wally speed but also
the lightning throw ability that we saw
zoom do at the beginning of season two
technically it was hunter zolomon
stubble masquerading as Jay Garrick that
taught Barry how to throw lightning but
the reason why malice is able to do this
a combine a couple of different Speed
Force abilities is just because he's so
powerful like they just want you to crap
your pants because it comes after a
moment where he literally says I don't
need the power of the totems anymore I'm
that much more powerful so if you don't
know whom allah' says you haven't been
watching legends of tomorrow think of
him is being like The Dark Knight's
metal villain someone who has power on a
multiversal level scale who's been
trapped beyond space-time so he's
powerful enough to break what you would
think of as the traditional rules of
everyone's powers on the TV show meaning
that if you wanted to he would probably
fly you'd probably beat Superman just
because he's not bound by reality at the
same way that normal people living in
this reality are giving speed sharing
speed taking speed all core flash comic
book concepts there's just a couple big
ones that we have not got to yet like
the idea that Barry could borrow some of
Wally's speed temporarily then give it
right back without requiring some sort
of mechanical transfer medium usually
there's some piece of technology that
Harrison wells or Cisco has to invent
like when they started siphoning speed
off a Barry during season two like it
was an actual physical device that they
had to plug in otherwise it wouldn't
work like zoom couldn't stand right next
to Barry put his hand on him and absorb
his speed for the way that God speed
kind of does that in the comics now
taking people speed in the comics is a
little bit different auguste heart can't
just walk up to Barry and touch him on
the shoulder and that's it you have to
sort of turn your body into a magnet for
the Speed Force so like I said everybody
who's a speedster is charged with dark
matter electricity you had kind of like
a conductor for electricity so they
turned themselves into sort of magnets
when they're stealing people's speed but
that requires that they run around them
at a specific velocity they also have to
psychically will themselves to take the
Speed Force while they're doing this so
there's this mental and physical aspect
to taking giving borrowing people speed
that they haven't got to on the TV show
yet because I think they're saving it
for a future season like I think they
don't want any one speedster to be
powerful that they could stand on the
other side of the room and just suck
someone's speedforce right out of them
the way the thinkers been doing it on
the TV show is more scientific like when
he plugs cables and other people and you
see those charges go through them as
he's transferring his consciousness what
he's doing is he's using the Speed Force
as a transfer medium to take the soup
that is his DNA combined with all the
other bust metas and beamed that into
other bodies so it wasn't clear it's not
like he's just using normal electricity
he is using the Speed Force but it's not
something that he innately possesses in
his DNA which is where Barry comes in
later this season and we all have
theories about how he's going to steal
the Speed Force from Barry by basically
stealing Barry's body itself
deteriorating rapidly
the additional Dark Matter in your
system from HIV new powers is wearing
down your host it's draining too much of
this body's new energy then I must move
into the next one you two are lucky
Barry your ears almost healed and did me
yours just stretched I still can't hear
all that great consider that a blessing
in disguise less twang in your future
give it an hour you'll be fine
like remember what's avatar's plan was
at the end of season three to exist
everywhere in all times that's kind of
what's happening with the thinker only
on a more mental level his mind is
growing so powerful with all the powers
of the metas that he's absorbed in his
intellect even though the TV shows are
borrowing a lot of things from God speed
I know a lot of people ask are they ever
gonna do him on the TV show like first
things first usually my stances is that
they're probably not gonna do anything
from the comics right now but they might
get to it later the things that they're
teasing right now are not really god
speed related like they're mostly
talking about coffee shop girl that's
the big mystery that they have to pay
off they can still take that in a
totally different direction but I
wouldn't be surprised if within the next
three episodes we get enough evidence to
definitively say who this person is now
the TV show usually doesn't confirm
everything to the very final episode but
usually before that if the TV show has
been doing a good job of setting up a
big twist you have enough clues to piece
that together if you're really looking
closely but when it comes to coffee shop
girl just remember back to season 2 with
the hunter zolomon zoom twist so
the identity reveal is one big part of
the equation the other big part of that
is what their plan is and zoom is a
really good example of a big character
twist like holy crap at zoom this is
awesome I can't believe they're doing
hunter zolomon who had a really crap
plan so what I'm really hoping is is
that the flash TV show learned their
lesson in coffee shop girl is there for
a really important reason that will tee
up a big arc next season but also the
payoff of who she is is also a big
reveal too so I know a lot of people are
wondering about iris being pregnant her
potentially being Barry and irises child
it is still possible for her to be berry
and irises child without iris being
pregnant right now which doesn't answer
any questions about why they made Cecile
pregnant on the TV show that might be
because of something that happened in
real life every once in a while an
actress on a TV show who's like a main
cast member will get pregnant and they
have a couple of options when something
like that happens but I don't know
anyone that was clamoring for Joe and
Cecile to have another baby on the flash
so I'm expecting some big twist
but post all your theories in the
comments below and hopefully that
explains a little bit about the
different ways that people transfer and
give speed like I said I think that will
get to Barry being able to do that by
himself in a future season but because
this season isn't a big speedster
villains season I think they're just
saving that for when we do have another
speedster villain what's gonna happen
later this week is because ready player
one is coming out I'll post my
non-spoilery review on Thursday there's
a new episode of Krypton arrow is still
on break so I'll update the video
schedule as I go along but
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Krypton video Joshua
Ojeda
please private message me so I can get
your contact details there'll be a new
round when I post new DC click here for
that Krypton Episode one video if you
haven't seen it yet and click here for
brand new infinity war thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight